eagle-eye wanna lose control for I'm
ready to roll and I've been dreamin
[Music]
feels like I've been walking on
everything going we gonna have a good
time
a dozen hands up to the sky we gonna get
roasted
I've been feeling it all day I wanna let
it go I wanna lose control I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
understood our political I
run toss to the lovers and so see you
and do when I do you and I
[Music]
you
you
up to the sky
[Music]
we got a spark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
long time
[Music]
feels like I've been walking in the sky
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's hump day hump someone you love if
you're Tamra judge hump Bronwyn Windham
Burke if you're Bronwyn Windham Burke
hump Tamra judge yeah I just caught up
on Real Housewives of Orange County
excuse me for the reference same looking
forward to recapping it at the end of
this show also Kardashian's I caught up
on which whole recap great yes it was
just like a day of recaps for me yeah
totally
but how could happy Wednesday welcome
back to the morning to help everyone had
I hope I could talk I hope everyone had
to a wonderful and fulfilling Tuesday
and I'm looking forward to an equally
wonderful even more fulfilling Wednesday
Claudia's very awake today so I blow my
hair last night like I was trying to be
you know prepared and I slept with my
hair like on my let's share hair well
you Scott like if you just looked at the
camera and if you know I don't want to
if we get all on top of my hair and for
some reason when you put your hair up
like your hair sometimes chooses to like
move in one direction and not go back
it's like your hair follicles are on of
sabbatical and I put my hair down this
morning and it wouldn't lay flat like
and I literally like greased it up I
don't know how to get my hair follicles
to go back down I look like I'm wearing
a Shadle and they grew up on a key boots
in Poland but I'm working on it but I
think the wig look suits you you're
wigging out today I have a guest flown
yep it's cool it is it's pretty cool
anyways we have great show for you today
some interest on stories some you know
minimal celebrity news that will just
make a mountain out of the usual Oh a
joke about Selena Gomez's new song no we
are not because we are of you of it okay
like I need I need to understand what's
going on in the world like it's a fine
song is it amazing no are the words like
not more than like wolves I've been
running yeah like it's better than her
previous crap but like the way people
are talking about this song like it's
written by like homer like it's the
Odyssey like it's a [ __ ] song like
enews holding back our tears like chill
the [ __ ] out like so it's just a bad pop
song oh you need to listen to it now
after I say this it's a Julianne Michael
song yeah
like no but she wrote it but it
literally sounds like Jillian Michaels
is singing and it's a song I've already
heard oh you know that is the theory
that Jillian Michaels is actually behind
the vocals it literally sounds listen to
in the bathroom this morning I was like
I've heard this song and it's Julia
Michaels then I saw that she wrote it
which is fine I didn't listen to that it
sounds just like Julia I overslept this
morning I didn't have any time for
frivolity
I listened to it last night at midnight
and then I was just like reading
people's like instagrams right it was
like a master post about it in the toast
why are we holding her hand like she's
the biggest pop star in the world so
it's by no means is it a bad so I get by
no means is it like the you know the
anthem of our generation like nobody
care about the song in the year people
are dissecting the lyrics because it's
about Justin Bieber and she hates him
right but let's me not forget like
Selena Gomez was in the room while Julia
Michaels wrote the song so Julia
Michaels wasn't married to Justin Bieber
right people like are always puzzled
let's me not forget Justin Bieber and
Selena Gomez broke up ten years ago he's
written so many songs about how she's
done with him she's done so many
interviews about how she's done with him
but she's still writing songs like he's
married bro like once the ones gets
migraine it's like it's like Nintendo
like game over yeah right link unless
there's a divorce like then you can come
out from out of your hole but just get
back whack-a-mole I found tog I just did
as always it's not the Sun that's
upsetting me it's like the world's
reaction to it just like it's and I
can't stress enough it's not a bad song
like it's fine song it's okay
but like everyone being like this song
just cured my acne like relax I have to
listen to it now snitch is it a
certified bop as our resident music
expert it's a good song it really is it
is yeah like and it's know like fetish
you know like it's finally good music
from Selena Gomez but I do understand
where home drum and it's also just crazy
because I've heard it already yeah bye
Julia Michaels agreed right I think
Julia Michaels was on Twitter responding
to people in the pop crave replies being
like Selena didn't write it with Mae you
know like please silly not relax
Selena get off her Twitter no we know
like it's fine now that one's a
songwriter like Katy Perry's not a
songwriter but she's still a [ __ ] pop
Larry is a songwriter
mm-hmm no no like that she lured
Harley's in Hawaii you know
like she is a songwriter say so for my
pops I don't believe we're written by
her like Teenage Dream um yeah no but
she like write songs for other people
it's a whole ecosystem she is a song
she's not is shalini who write songs for
other guess what is she written like I
don't know why cheerin has written a
bunch of songs Kelly Clarkson has
written some songs with one direction
I just idea Kelly Clark's Katelyn area
songs written for other artists I'm
pretty sure this is true so um I just
want to give credit to her even though
Harley's in Hawaii is like the promo for
harlots in Hawaii although it's very
toasty it's like okay songs written by
Katy Perry Black Widow by Iggy Azalea
that's actually a really good song yeah
that song yes you do um hold on I'm just
this is a confusing list Oh Nicki Minaj
song called get on your knees okay um a
long shot which is a Kelly Clarkson song
that's a great song I don't know that
song either you know it's nitch what she
wrote a Britney Spears song Wow yes
she's a songwriter okay I take it back
but not every pop stars a songwriter and
that's okay and that is okay you can be
both or you can be one Julia Michaels
tried to be a pop star didn't work out
you couldn't be neither right like yeah
no no you say pop star yes I think you
didn't write the song very truly did
have influence I said that would be like
the same as Selena Gomez it's like toast
was written because it was like your
what was inside of you but you didn't
write it I would literally never in my
life take credit for writing note oh I'm
not saying I wouldn't and I wouldn't
even have the gall to it like this like
it wouldn't exist if he you weren't the
one singing oh of course
so like maybe that's the where's the
Selena Gomez applies here it's like she
didn't write it but it's like a has to
do with her experience perhaps but I
just need everyone to relax when it
comes to the Selena Gomez of it all I
know people are like up in arms that we
hate her so much I don't hate her at all
I don't think she's a good role model
first of all you don't or you do don't
okay it was it was unclear what he said
I really don't and I just don't get the
blind loyalty that's it it's like okay
even if I don't like someone like I know
why there stands like that it's like
Selena Gomez is the biggest fans in the
world and she doesn't like worked in
like five years
no I
need more from my artist than what she
provides like she just gives what she
wants other people to see him I feel
like there's so much about her that we
don't now but like you compared to
someone like ariana grande who [ __ ]
bleeds out every single day for her fans
it's just like I prefer that sort of
artist also I just don't really get not
that you should be putting women against
each other it's just something we like
to dabble in but I just don't get what
there is to stand it's like a song a
year maybe it's no appearances like it's
an Instagram it's an Instagram post
right before she's gonna post a coach ad
let you put a selfie just so it's not
all sponsored content like I don't just
I don't get what there is just I think
the scan the salary comes from years ago
but these people are loyal like one day
people just decided like they love
Selena Gomez from like Wizards of
Waverly Place and for a while she really
was like on the machine and I think now
they loved her so much that and now they
see that she's struggling and so that
has turned into like love and support
for her no matter what happens it's kind
of like Britney Spears
yeah but her stands aren't nearly as
nuts as this Selena Gomez man it's just
because they're older and they are
really busy that's sure like they have
jobs kids can even have kids yeah who
are fans of Selena Gomez they're
wondering why lol Lord that was such an
actor the laughs like like yeah I was
really laughing Wow
so are you fake laughing every other
time no it was just a different sort of
life like an unexpected life because it
was just a different was just like ha ha
ha you know like you were really like
verbalizing the lab I guess I don't know
funny also bronwen's laughs I make sure
never to laugh again
bronwen's laugh on OC is actually a
treat and it sounds like they're playing
like a
Audio over everything but they're not
she was doing it I'm watching up and
slide as well and it's cool to see that
like someone actually laughs like that
all them do anyways we do have a
squatter again today like please remind
him it's so hard not to mind him I'm
filled with rage but he's like fallen on
hard times like speaking of squatters
like we started talking about sweaters
yesterday I never in my [ __ ] life
because someone sent me this video it
was the most shocking video of this guy
whose food kept disappearing in his
apartment and he thought it was his
girlfriend so he tried like
turn the act and put up a camera and
went to sleep and the squatter came out
of the wall and spent the night watching
TV drinking from his fridge from the
carton that's that's Jackie unforgivable
hanging in his sink no why couldn't he
pee in his toilet it was a girl and I
don't know she didn't want to leave the
kitchen area that makes it even worse
so she's there for like literally like
like they keep fast-forwarding like
she's in the kitchen she's in the living
room and then all of a sudden she hears
something I guess he gets up to go get
some water in the middle of the night
while the squatters out she hears a
footstep you've never seen someone
[ __ ] moved so goddamn fast I don't
know where she went cuz she went off
camera to hide he walked out got a cup
of water way back to sleep she went back
like it - to finagling but then the most
shocking part is the Nexus - she went
back up in the next morning he goes out
he's ready for the day he's leaving the
house
he drinks orange juice from the carton
that she drank from last night she's
drink from the carton MHMR couldn't you
burn that's what I said was like so
unbelievably he touches like right then
nothing they have a ghost but so clearly
this guy had cameras in his home right
he set one up because he thought his
girlfriend was eating all their food but
it was this squatter and this girl comes
lucky without this girl comes like
climbing out of the wall and she looks
so - crud but it was like it scared me I
didn't go to sleep till 2:00 in the
morning I was so freaked out
that's horrible there actually aren't a
lot of squatter security footage tapes
on the internet like I thought I was
gonna fall down like a huge rabbit hole
after someone sent me this one video and
you really can't find a lot because I
guess they're so hard to find so this
video was like really premium I truly
can I mean I know one video I won't be
watching today
no Margo please it's so crazy I showed
it to Ben and now he's because also
before we went to bed we were going to
other places at her home a squatter
could hypothetically live yeah I mean of
commercial air conditioning units and
they're behind this like big closet and
it's like we never look in the closet
the squatters water bill you wanna sleep
obviously our squatter is like getting
really insecure now because I don't know
because now he's being quiet because he
knows we're on he's in the walls and
he's banging around some pipes
yeah I think he might be like working on
the plumbing honestly he's probably
toaster who just wanted to come watch a
live taping what's good what's good what
what make yourself comfortable squat
what uh what scoop okay well I'm glad
that I didn't
choose the Selena Gomez's talking to the
story it's me basically already covered
up ya know but like I chose it so that
we wouldn't cover it but I'm glad that
we covered it even though I didn't want
to okay I'm sorry
no it's fine I just like I hate that
sort of like quote unquote news right
like when someone releases a song oh
they get means absolutely nothing okay
what Oh Katy Perry's riding harleys in
her Hawaii
like I hope she's wearing a helmet like
I don't give a [ __ ] no I know and now
that we're talking about it like can we
talk about how sad like the promo for
Harley's in Hawaii was nice to see sad
no I know but like literally nowhere
oh yeah well then oh I check I didn't
even hear about the song I only heard
about the artwork because it was toasty
well I added it to my like songs and I
gave it a chance and it was yesterday
morning when I had to remove it from
playing really yeah it's just not good
it's so weird
she was almost there she was almost nuts
there took at least two songs ago the
good one I guess it's never really just
because it doesn't mean it's really over
slaps and oh she's back we're getting
you know prism then she released once
another song small talk
chitchat small talk awful yeah
hers and white like the name is just
like so not it and it's like I really
thought she was back but it's looking
like maybe she wasn't also it's like in
brie watching Glee they love Katy Perry
so I get to hear all of her like music
and it's like wow like I can't believe
we had all those songs and now like she
can't do it that's how she became like a
bonafide she's an icon like that's how
she's sitting on the panel of American
Idol like the work that she put in those
years Teenage Dream like that was the
work that made her what she is and look
now she that happens with a lot of
people like now she literally can't put
out a good song for her life that's like
Christina Aguilera yeah except Lotus is
so underrated of an album oh so under it
so many Blake Shelton uh just a fool Oh
excellent
yeah that's where I'm Lotus yeah what
see no one like the ballad that I have
in my head and I can date literally
playing page all of them are incredible
cease fire
aren't you justice for that I'll be like
it was considered a flop and it was her
best work yet that's the worst right
like well because then it's like what's
the point you know I think people don't
even appreciate art no so then it's like
the music that is successful is like the
cheap like pop songs so then they'll
just continue to put out more of that
and not like the real meaningful I mean
you take that flops I think it was
yeah no but like light up the sky yeah
yeah sometimes the cheap hop songs are
great to like joke knock on those right
but these this just happened to be like
a masterful work of art and it was just
like it was so unnoticed yeah I just it
made me upset
it's like um native OneRepublic yeah
it's like was considered that's my
question
Lotus is on like a list of yeah om so
yeah I just I know I've said it once
before but I feel like it's been a while
since we've ever started that native is
probably the best album release in the
last 20 years
you know no way would say Lotus was
released him in last 20 years by way
better than motifs native is like an
album like I will never say no to yeah
anyway I'm on the car I'm on a plane I'm
at a party put it on I'm on vinyl I'm on
vinyl yeah I think there's album after
that what was it called I might prefer
that one Oh life in color that's native
no I guess it is what's the one okay we
have this mutation once somebody who are
they if I'm looking at it yeah it's all
me it's you think like there's no way
there's that many good songs in our
album this one is I lived if I lose
myself love runs out counting stars
sending it okay you can't stop you're
right like you're right sunshine is a
freakin Bob no right if you've never
listened to that album and you want to
have like a cultural awakening
feel free to listen to spiritual
whatever or you just want to wake the
[ __ ] up listen to this album it's
beautiful okay well without further ado
twenty minutes later the squatter fell
asleep it is time to deliver the fast
eye stories that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast I guess that's the thing
about squatters think they sleep during
the day so they can come out at night
and drink your orange juice yeah so they
should be quiet he's not a very good
squatter yeah like he just should have
got he probably just went to bed yeah
from from the night it's time to deliver
the fat side stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning to has come but I do
have to let everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by one of our
favorite sponsors open fit it takes all
the complexity out of losing weight and
getting fit it's a brand new super
simple streaming service that allows you
to work out from the comfort of your
living room in as little as 10 minutes a
day so we're all about bettering
ourselves from the comfort of our own
homes an open pit is just that you can
get all the workouts tips and tricks you
need without
leaving your apartment so you never have
to leave Theo and you can just break a
sweat and then hop the shower not to
risk anyone seeing you with your sweaty
upper lip you know you co can even do it
with you like it's not necessarily work
out for dogs but like why can't then you
can work out with amazing trainers like
Andrea Rogers who's the founder of the
worldwide sensation extend bar or the
newest workout rough-around-the-edges
with six of the most badass young women
on in the business you can no longer
worry about others watching your workout
or feel the pressure to keep up with
Pearce at the gym open fit is great for
all it's affordable and accessible some
places only sell classes as a package
and often you can't make it to every
class open fit brings the class to you
you'll get what you put in you see
results within the first 30 days open
fit has changed the way that we workout
and texting our code toasts to 30 30 30
you can join us on our fitness journey
personalized just for you right now
during the open fit 30 day challenge our
listeners will get a special extended
30-day free trial membership to open fit
when you text toast to 30 30 30 that's
three zero three zero three zero you
will get full access to open fit all the
workouts and nutritional information
totally free again just text toast to
thirty thirty thirty three zero three
zero three zero
I'm standard message and data rates they
might apply no promises
sign on look amazing yeah yeah okay
first story just some beautiful
beautiful munis from some beautiful
beautiful people
Maren Morris is pregnant expecting a
baby boy with her husband Ryan heard it
shocks me to the core that the the
toasters new this did you know that yes
I heard it from the snitch I read it in
the toasters thread I'm like no way but
then every time I saw a picture or
something Mary Morris was doing I was
just looking at it through the lens like
hmm is she hiding a bump and it's like
yes she was but like or she could have
just been wearing like you know a new
dress like maybe she's frozen in the
mint or things and I just think this is
so great like it's just cool unlike
people who are at the height of their
game like they don't um postpone like
their their maternal needs you know
someone might think like this is do you
know the biggest Meyer in March is ever
gonna get cheese on this huge tour like
maybe she should wait a few years no you
can have it all you can have it all and
she had a really sweet caption and the
irony is just too rich that after a year
of living in the girl headspace the
universe would give us a baby boy to eat
in things out the singer captioned a
photo of herself with heard cradling her
baby bump quote see you in 2020 little
one those pictures are so cute I can't
look they just came out like yeah it's a
baby and it's
like there's no like whether we have
gender yeah like I hate that [ __ ] like I
hate that [ __ ] you know I'm gonna do it
you know you're gonna have a gender
reveal oh uh oh my god like are you
gonna find out the sex before you have
the bet yeah I don't know yet I got a
prepare surprise
no but you don't prepare you don't buy
anything before you have a better you do
know you don't not as you know I mean
not it's like a her ad jus like you
would need a nursery in [ __ ] you can set
it up I don't know you can get a crib
you need to be able to bring them home
yeah look at the crib like that day no
you definitely don't want to do anything
before like the six-month mark but like
what would you be doing anyway but like
I'm not trying to give myself more work
when there's a bit in the world like you
know I'm buying that crib nut chiller
I'm getting that free shoulder without
all the influencers have I'm getting it
no I'm spending the big bucks I'm
getting that like old-school pink
stroller I don't know what it's called
but it looks like what if you ever
bought old school pink stroller it's
called I don't see gender so what's the
point having a gender-reveal very
honestly gender appeals are really going
out of style right go kart K I know
they're quite controversial well why
wears nobody talking about that I don't
know I don't know man
that's next frontier um also what a my
favorite things to do besides watching
squadra videos is to watch like mishap
gender reveals
oh that's like they put it in a balloon
in the balloon flies away for as much
smack as I talk about gender never
actually watched want like a dunce yeah
I don't like how I live on the internet
and have never seen I see that they
exist and I just like to scroll right by
them you know I scroll it's called the
Silver Cross they yeah the thing the
Silver Cross pink silver cause I mean
yeah pink because it's supposed to match
to me the baby doesn't see color yeah I
just need one that has like lots of them
for a sax and maybe like I'm a lock and
key I could keep the kid in you know
yeah like a safe yeah like unless Ryan
Reynolds what he uses for Blake I can't
even
well I'm so excited for Maron oh this is
so great this is so great I love a good
Bevin news and now cam the country's
is married so it's just like a new
generation of country singer no I mean I
yeah I'm not gonna like now put pressure
on other women to have children nobody
like I can think of a few country
artists like but in this photo could get
pregnant I just feel like in country
it's like a thing where like all the
women like they they don't put career or
family first like they do at all like
they're all married super young they're
having kids now like I think that's
really admirable what a great role
models a hundred percent 100 percent
anyways a hundred percent are you ready
for an x-ray about the accidental role
model while I can who's celebrating one
year of sobriety crazy diner prompt
world star Lala Kent is celebrating a
year of clean living quote today I am
one year sober she shared on Instagram
this is the biggest accomplishment I've
ever had in my life and the one I'm most
proud of the moments I've had in the
past year have been a blessing that I've
been present for I didn't have that
before today I will celebrate my
one-year birthday because it's exciting
it is also humbling because today and
every day after that I will fight for it
but I won't give it up for anything Wow
I remember when she went on watch what
happens live and she told Andy chemin as
a drink since October and now it's
October again and she's celebrating her
one year sober anniversary and I just
think it's incredible like I'm so happy
for her proud of her like that must be
so difficult especially in the world
that she lives in like think about us
turning down a drink it seems so hard
meanwhile we're like nobodies but she's
somebody like going to the irishman with
Martin Scorsese can't have a drink and
I'm so incredibly proud of her me too
and I just I think anyone who is sober
is my hero it's so impressive but given
the line of work that she's in like this
is even more impressive and she has
managed to say stay so relevant like
people who don't drink or don't party
like you you kind of get left out of the
drama because everyone's like heightened
emotions you're getting [ __ ] up
screaming at each other at a club in
Mexico so it really would have been easy
for her to kind of fade to the
background but she's still like the
biggest star in that show and like
Sheena drinks all the time couldn't do
more relevant you know yeah but we
actually haven't had a sober season from
her yet this one coming up because
member they did go to Mexico and she was
showing each other panic attacking but I
agree with you that she'll be as
relevant anymore and like maybe you know
some of her House members could like
learn a thing or two about sober living
I feel like all of the Vanderpump rules
kids are genuinely like over drinking
not over drinking like they're over the
fat the thought of drinking but because
it's been such a big part of their
success I feel like maybe if they think
they'll stop like it'll affect their
success you know you need but then so do
you think that they don't drink when
they're not filming like they don't
trick is not kind of I mean they'll just
watch two million dollar houses like
they now really think of bitter pearls
like us their job yeah it's not just
like fun we're getting payments it's
like no they're starting families
they're all getting married now like
they're gonna have kids they have homes
like this is their job yeah can we talk
about Lila Kent and the Irishman press
tour um all of it also there were been
posters around La for the Irishman and
they just like I didn't see Randall's
name on any of them I was even reading
the fine print well he's a producer so I
think if there's ever like a
behind-the-scenes person's name on a
poster it's a director like James
Cameron's Martin's ass yeah so I don't
think a producer would really ever be on
it unless it was produced by like when
it's Paltrow you know like yes so that's
not shocking the fine print does shock
me though ya know like I was up really
close to Bill where you can see
everything and I just I didn't see it
not like saying that he's but he's
definitely involved okay yeah I mean
she's on the carpet with Scorsese it's
so crazy it's incredible and she really
looks perfect like four she looks like
herself but also looks like you know
wife of producer right hello Paris yeah
it's just so funny how like she plates
two roles she wears two hats like she's
like this event like this reality star
like this trashy show you know and then
she's also like a future Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills because she ain't even
closer to that because she's Erika Jayne
and she's sister Artie and she's Erika
Jayne and she's Lila Kent and she's
missing it yeah when do you think
they're gonna be married on TV no I mean
they they have a date and I think it'll
be in the spring or summer
yeah but they they film in the spring
actually Randall is pretty open
advertisers have never been on the show
so he's oh my god oh my god we have to
talk about something I'm gonna put the
iPad down for this because Kylie Jenner
is doing one of those giveaways Lou the
time I saw and that you have to follow
75 accounts that Scott Disick is
following and I only had followed one of
the accounts already and it was Randall
Emmett who is participating in this
giveaway to get followers stop wait okay
so hold on hold on so it's the people
that Scott follows yes
bless you I want to see if I know anyone
else that is so loser I can't believe
you found that out your genie I know
well there were other like huge colossal
losers of extraordinary loser honestly I
think these people deserve to be called
out for being losers so if I know if
they've ever heard of anything you know
what they're getting around 200,000
followers the toasters have been keeping
up with one of their least favorite
bloggers who's a part of it and they're
comparing how many she had before and
after yeah so they're getting around
200,000 followers um so really little
thing okay but like that's fine there
are thirsty cup like their brand brand
it's less crazy to me cuz like you got
to do what you got to do honestly we
should join one of these giveaways I
know
200,000 followers like that except me
it's not real and they don't know how
much you've to pay um you know whatever
these people and I once got an email to
join one of these things okay first of
all talentless is in here Fran and
whether they've 977 thousand also
Raising Cane's Margot thank you guys you
guys is weird it's a chain in the south
I got an email to join one of these
things by the way I've gotten them too
and I and I followed up to see how much
you get paid oh you don't get paid you
paid wait no no cuz I would be the one
posting Louis Vuitton oh that's
embarrassing like yeah and there's no
reward for you know the reward is they
give you a flat fee that was just like
not acceptable and you you can earn
commission like I know you can't I want
to be one of the people I'll pay I want
to know how much it is wait where was
the part where they talked about that
everyone pays to get in to it but I get
these emails all the time I think it's
like someone subscribing to some email
and I delete them but I should really
read them because it's fascinating
during this campaign our page at I won't
say will be following 40 to 65 pages
with paid to be part of this giveaway
all of the accounts that we'll be paying
to be a part of this will be similar
nisha accounts to yours this is where
this is an organic way for other
influencers to grow their IG pages while
also giving popular influencers like you
thank you the chance to give back to
your followers and in warding one of
them with $2,000
I'm sorry I didn't get back guys wait I
want it I want to do it I don't know how
much it is I heard it's like 15 grand
well I think when it's on Kylie's page
she probably gets paid let's say I think
happened
million dollars for this at least that
means there were how many counts that
were that Webley was five hundred
thousand two by the wayside and Scott is
a part of it around $6,500 hmm
interessant like I don't want to be the
one posting the photo I wanted money in
there laning the followers oh you know
what I really want to see hoop nation by
Alexis was in there which is actually oh
she's this 216 that's great yeah no like
for your brand
where's new for the toes I know because
even we would get to in 2000 like not
toasters obviously but like maybe like
to ensure to 200 with us people like
might toasters and train it might be
interesting it right like might have to
follow us and be like oh this is pretty
cool these girls are beautiful and smart
and like wonderful the toasters
potential toasters potential toasters TI
t tips toasters and training yeah I
don't know maybe I should reach back out
me I'm not interested in this format but
like I'd love to me out but I understand
he just missed like a big one like the
Kylie one that's what I would have
wanted to be on yeah I want to be on a
Kardashian one yeah okay we'll come back
to it anyway thought it was interesting
that Randle was there but then I
remember for his birthday like a year
ago he started with Khloe Kardashian and
she bit we're all like he wants for his
birthday
monsters birthdays followers so I guess
he's at least consistent and I already
follow him so honestly it's pretty
premium content is it yeah he posted
cute stuff of him and Lala he posted
like the new Gulfstream plane that just
say beautimous actually pretty
interesting was huge wow I got to see
that I would have never seen it anywhere
right so just a little something to
think about aviation experts see that
kind of stuff
all the time right when you're friends
with the points guys right it's hard to
be impressed
okay next story is just so sweet and
just setting the bar high for husbands
everywhere Kanye West donates 1 million
dollars to prison reform charities for
Kim Kardashian's birthday oh my god yes
so she posted on her Instagram a picture
saying she had the best birthday ever
explaining what they did her mom and
Kanye hosted a party for her at her
house where carousel their favorite
Armenian restaurant could they go to an
anniversary their dad's death catered
she said she got the most amazing
presents from her family like some great
bags from Kanye but most importantly um
he also donated 1 million dollars to her
favorite charities that worked so hard
on prison reform on behalf from him and
kids that is so sweet like I could die
so sweet well so I just caught up on
Kardashians when she was talking about
how someone wrote her a letter from
prison asking like to get their tattoo
removed but they couldn't afford it
wait I didn't see that yeah what episode
was that on I'm not caught up it was meh
callous or two episodes ago I hit me on
the set
yes so basically like she was so busy
they were talking about how busy she was
um and she's like and I have to go do
this thing like some guy wrote me from
prison about this tattoo that he'd like
needs to get removed but he can't cuz he
can't afford laser so like I told his
mom I would pay for it cuz he gave me
his mom's phone number in the letter she
went and like took care of it it was so
cute oh my god that's so cute I can't
even miss that one yeah because when she
was sitting on the couch I think between
the mecca on the after party oh when she
was turning into her blue look yeah I
think yeah so weird uh it was actually a
really good episode very interest on so
interest on we will get into it I need
to like get all my thoughts back to the
top of my mind um but before we do that
Lauri Lachlan has been hit with
additional charge in the College
Admission scandal before we do that are
you ready to own the now no I know um
today's episode is also brought to you
by one of our most prestigious and
business savvy sponsors vistaprint the
most important time is now the
importance of feeling professional
polished and prepared when it counts is
right now for small business owners like
ourselves or people who produce her on
podcasts being plugged in and prepared
when an opportunity comes up is crucial
and having a business card that shows
how professional you are in your pocket
ready to hand out is the first step to
making that happen we always say on the
show the worst time to realize you need
a business card is right after someone
asks you for one you never look like
more of a messy piece of [ __ ] than dad
being asked for a business card or not
having one it's like oh I can give you
my email like a garage over you like no
bro
like I had a [ __ ] business card get
your [ __ ] together or it's like oh I'll
get your number and then you're creeped
yeah right oh yeah like what is this
1972 oh no it's like what do you ask me
on these can you're [ __ ] harder but
our bug off ready to get started on your
business card it's super easy plug in
your information and logo into hundreds
of fresh designs to that tailored to
your type of company or upload your own
design original layout pick the paper
stocks
in quantity that's right for you you can
even upgrade to unique touch like
rounded corners you can order and
receive your cards with free economy
shipping you can feel good knowing that
vistaprint news is only carefully
selected inks and responsibly sourced
paper stocks your satisfaction is 100%
guaranteed or your money back they will
make it right
miss dupré wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to vistaprint.com enter
promo code toast for free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity limited time offer on the now
at Vista Print dot-com promo code toast
you will support our show when you
support our sponsors so feel free to get
your [ __ ] together and head to
vistaprint.com use code toast feel free
to get your [ __ ] together sign on get
your [ __ ] together ok speaking of [ __ ]
not together Lori Loughlin has been hit
with an additional charge in the College
Admission scandal she is among 11
parents who on Tuesday were hit with
more charges in the National College
Admission scandal her husband Massimo
was also charged with the new count
according to the new indictment the 11
allegedly quote conspired to commit
federal program bribery by bribing
employees of the university of southern
california to facilitate their
children's admission in exchange for the
bribes employees of the university
allegedly designated the defendants
children as athletic recruits with
little or no regard for their athletic
abilities or as members of other favored
admissions categories so this just seems
like more of the same but you're like
they're really cracking down now the
felicity is in the jumpsuit like all
bets are off now it's like really in
hindsight like felicity is legal team
really advised her in the best manner
like she she could have been one of
those people who got hit with another
charge but she pled guilty she didn't
waste the Court's time and she's doing
her time I don't know it's not done yet
like it's not done yet is all I have to
say same but it's just not looking good
and like if all Lori Loughlin has to do
is spend 12 days in like a very low but
like high budget low security prison
just to risk not being charged more or
like I think she really totally made the
right move and to society ladies not
it's not gonna be 12 days and it wasn't
gonna be even if she pled guilty it
wouldn't be 12 days what's the oven no
Lori Lachlan he said it well Lori
Loughlin has oh he's just right Felicity
Huffman yeah
like and and Felicity Huffman going to
jail farmer PR perspective makes it seem
like she understands her punishment she
understands what cheated was wrong and
it might make it easier for her to like
rehabilitate and like get back into into
Hollywood and get back to work
because she's no longer criminals she's
rehabilitated but with this Lori
Loughlin thing I don't know and it's
just like in now now it's more charges
being dragged on even longer we'll be
talking about this even longer
Olivia Chi that's going to take longer
to get back on YouTube like I just I
don't know where it ends for Lori
Loughlin and I see where it ends for
Felicity Huffman in like a week in a
week
yeah I wonder if she's gonna do any
press after like a sit-down interview
she's not that thirsty and she's not
that desperate like I think she's
[ __ ] embarrassed like no and I think
also it's like if she wasn't doing
interviews sit-down tell-alls before
like she doesn't need to do them now she
doesn't owe us anything I'm not like you
know needing to hear every detail about
her her personal life I didn't know
anything about her before it was enjoy
her work like I think a lot of people
didn't even know she was married to
William H Macy until they were walking
into court together no she was walking
out alone Oh true but he did come to
pick her up yeah that was nice that
whole thing was weird
no it's still weird yeah and how he
wasn't charged at all and it's like has
he been visiting can someone get eyes on
that but I'm not gonna lie like of the
two of them who could handle prison look
at uh I would agree but you just I feel
like Laurie Laughlin's gotta fight her
inside of her sorry no I was talking
about will mhm me to see and that I
don't think Frank Frank no like I'm the
two of them like I really feel like
Lesley Hoffman can handle prison yeah I
don't know them no me neither but I'm
pretending like I do yeah I'm with
Felicity Laughlin like I don't I do not
think she can handle prison like she
doesn't give me like that
tough [ __ ] like the bad she's she's
standing her ground here I know which
makes me think like is there more to the
story
because she seems so sure that she's not
gonna be convicted but he said when
you're guilty like you take the deal you
do yeah or you run the risk of getting
away work like if you know you're guilty
here you go to option I wonder what deal
they offered her right I don't know
maybe she can offer one yeah like if you
know you're guilty they're giving you a
deal where it's like you have to do time
but it's not nearly as bad as it could
be
or you can take a risk and like maybe
get off or get like a much worse
sentence but you know you're guilty what
do you take in the deal right I guess it
depends on
they have also it depends on if you're
like a gambler you know mm-hmm
gamble with your life yeah I would so
take the deal I'm like I'm out yet
totally lahardee down and if I watch if
I learned anything from watching lawn
otter
it's a you always state to do yeah
through the final story is a little
interesting ratings news that I saw it
would be interesting because Kelly
Clarkson's new talk show is a hit and
here's why here's why it's a big deal so
it's hard to figure out if the Kelly
Clarkson this is more of an opinion
piece by CNN business but I appreciated
their opinions it is hard to figure out
if the Kelly Carson show is a daytime
variety show or a daytime talk show
whatever it is it's working with viewers
since debuting last month the show is
averaging roughly 1.9 million viewers
per so that's good enough to put her in
fourth place among daytime talk show so
according to Nielsen fourth place may
not seem like much but the show was just
syndicated by NBCUniversal television is
only much behind shows that have been on
the air for years that includes Ellen
live with Kelly and Ryan and dr. Phil
which has led to a time talk with an
average of 3.1 million viewers per
episode so far this season
time out I found out something crazy
last night McGraw Jordan McGraw who
opens up for the James brothers was a
song with Sarah Hyland it's dr. Phil son
because dr. Phil is Phil McGraw yes like
how we got so far and nobody knows who
he is yeah I start to feel somewhere dr.
Phil's son maybe dr. Phil laughs give a
listen yeah yeah interesante Clarkson
also outranks other established shows in
daytime including Maori dr. oz Wow
Rachael Ray she's also bringing in
bigger ratings in another daytime new
could newcomer Tamron Hall they like
pretty much that shows at this at the
same time but in in Tamron halls defense
they promoted Kelley way more than they
promote at ameralik I didn't even know
time we got a show yeah I feel so like a
different kind of show like Cameron's
not doing Kelly okey no cameras very
like sit-down interview style yeah it's
not there to compare the two of them but
they're just giving us like a bunch of
different comparisons and I just think
this is great news for the industry I
love Kelly okie and you want to know
what I'd like about Kelly's show is that
I've never actually watched it but yeah
but I loved it and I just threw or gap
organically I've been like had clips
like sent to me or someone retweeted it
and I get to see like the nice step that
she's doing like I live for a Kelly okay
like somehow it's always retweeted
almost every day I think one of the
people I follow who's like a housewives
is also a Kelly Clarkson standing
retweets everything she does also then
she had Craig Morgan perform and like
everyone was crying so that clip went by
oh my god then she had chance the rapper
on and they were like vibing so hard and
then she also Christina Aguilera on and
then this conversation about how Kelly
Clarkson never knew that Christina
Aguilera was one of the main writers on
behind the scene one of one of Kelly's
like hit songs and they were talking
like the industry's always a Keaney
females apart like it was really just
like an interesting conversation so
she's doing interesting things and it
keeps coming across my desk without me
ever having to watch it yeah and that's
the sign of success in this Danny yeah
um anyways this is a big deal because as
you know it's almost impossible to
succeed in daytime and other popular
musicians like Harry Connick jr. Queen
Latifah have tried their hands at
daytime and failed even veteran
interviewers like Meredith Vieira
struggled to find an audience yeah that
was terrible but you know what if I'm
really shocking Queen Latifah's show not
taking off like I think she's so
relatable I feel like everyone loves her
maybe he was like a little bit before
she was like appreciated as a queen she
really is maybe but it's also like you
can be an incredible person everyone can
love you but that doesn't mean you're
gonna succeed in daytime television it's
really this hard nut to crack but what's
crazy it's like we kind of knew that
Kelly Clarkson show would be a success
from the minute it was like announced a
year and a half ago and I don't know
maybe we're just like let's call it a
tie let's call it out what do you think
about your Barrymore show do you think
it's gonna be a hit I don't I don't I do
okay it's not gonna be as big as Kelly
probably though I think it will be a
success also I have some information to
share and information just opinion just
experience smear on the lady gang
podcast which everyone should check out
and they posted a clip of our audio on
their Instagram and I like was listening
to it and for the first time in my life
I couldn't understand myself like I was
talking so fast and slurring
ice learn ow okay I think I need to go
to some sort of vocal coach to work on
my speed and enunciation diction my
diction as well I just think I get so
lazy I just like talking about words but
I really did you that yeah I know I
really need to work on my delivery well
lady gang it's like it was great but
there's four people which makes you feel
like you have to talk faster because
you're taking up like three other
people's time
so maybe listen to like a toast episode
maybe or NIC vials episode when that
comes out it looks like it's gonna be
next week because that can Tilly's on
this week yeah um which is fine because
we just have a game that's good to split
it up you know each week bringing in new
audiences oh yeah Dave why whoa whoa
so yeah that's mine let's recap Oh sake
let because OSI Fashion Week was last
night and it was the event of the season
according to Bronwyn um I have to say a
party on a boat is never a good thing
when it was like a 3-tiered like cruise
ship fashion show it was so weird
honestly sounds like a nightmare and why
did they have to move upstairs just to
finish the fashion show I mean no
goddamn sense to me I don't know but
that whole interaction with that lady
was [ __ ] brilliant because first of
all the whole thing started with um dr.
Beth is that her name dr. dead doctor
dead
I'm like starting a fight with this
random dude and I believe he's
repurposed Lydia's mom and like cast her
again
they gave her a wig I when I was
watching that whole scenario unfold I
was very much on the side of the dude
being like this doctor Jeb is a little
nuts and I don't really believe anything
she says and like
let's say the guy wasn't security and
that's where she was going like that's
not that crazy like you know what you
didn't know that she was a part of the
show she could go upstairs before
everyone else it felt like she was being
a little extra like overreacting
but you know it's like that's okay like
she's an older when we treated pal come
to us she felt like someone's touching
her like okay say sorry and move on it
was not like she's here you know like it
was very similar to when Aviva Drescher
his dad showed up at that event that
Ramona was hosting and brought a check
and touched her arm and she was like at
a women's event you were a charity you
were for domestic abuse
you want to touch me but I leave the
dress for his dad was like a freak yeah
but still like the level of drama I mean
yeah I I guess I don't know it was weird
like it could have just been nothing but
then that woman or all right so it could
have ended there like if that woman
hadn't done what she did like we would
have never even seen the clip of her
arguing with the security guard on
interesting until Kathy Moreno had
looked rubber name is Katherine Marino
she is that if that wasn't
Chinn for a housewife she got thorough
she was [ __ ] crazy when she was
walking around with the microphone oh my
god hashtag bully like I could die like
it was so cringy it was so funny like
and actually really respect the women
for like backing down because like she
was obviously thirsty and just like
looking for a fight and they could have
like you know that's a Kelly's button
like she'll go off in a New York minute
but she didn't and I I was glad for that
no Sam I think this week and last week's
episode of OC have been the best in so
long I had everything anything last week
was great because it was like all the
fun energy that you loved from
housewives and this week was just like
the mundane funniness of housewives also
the inherent sadness of a fashion week
that isn't New York Milan or Paris right
like remember I'm Brooklyn Fashion Week
in New York housewives the season one
like that is classic Housewives like
pretending like this Lane event is like
fashionable like oh yeah um actually the
altercation between Cathy Marina and the
women was giving me like season 1 vibes
where like they would just run into
strangers and have like random acts
fight that we're like cringy and about
nothing like that used to be so much of
the bread and butter of housewives now
they fight about like you put me in the
paper and like right they have like
these new celebrity problems where they
you should just be nobody something like
nobody problems and it was it harks back
to that time I thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious
Andy really needs to get her on what
Traven's like she was a star so I'm
watching Evans ID last night he had
Brown winning Garry Jannetty I saw he
asked them is some if she should be a
housewife
oh I'm Gary Jeannette he was like I
would give her a call back but yeah but
no and I thought that Andy was being a
little condescending towards Bronwyn
like and a little judgmental about like
her lifestyle choices and it was kind of
like disappointing to me was her first
time and watch what happens live and
like she's been so open with us as you
were yeah you know she's not my favorite
but I'm coming to like her more and more
and she's like carving out a place for
herself in housewives that no one is yet
you know no one else is gonna like get
down and make out with them this is a
new dynamic that is like it's fun and
interesting to watch I'm different right
and like Andy was just was asking her
about some of the things that she's like
spoken about on the show and she had
like really great answers and she was
talking about how this has created
within her family and she was like we're
not like other families like we are
different and I'm cool with that
he was like yeah it was just it was a
network and a person who's like so
progressive it was like she's just out
here trying to be herself like I don't
and it was their first time meeting Andy
and Brennan's first time meeting like I
just had a pit for her that's really
jealous judging her yeah when it's like
even if you don't agree with her like at
least be respectful of the fact that
she's like sharing her whole life
true roses for they show that's really
upsetting actually like it makes me sad
but um she was being insane last night
that's also just the vibe that I got
that's true her outfit was out of
control like one of the ugliest things
I've ever seen in my life the top sure
it didn't fit like it was so much action
material and the back of her tits were
popping out like it's called a Taylor
sweetie and look at that but I want to
talk about Adaline okay she's stunning
she's fine and I think they're trying to
go like the Gigi Hadid route you know
the issue is that Shannon is not Yolanda
I know and so not only is it like does
she not have like the expertise to share
with Adeline but like Adeline doesn't
respect her because it's not like her
mother used to be gracing the covers of
Vogue Navarre yeah you know yeah so it's
not the same no not at all but I think
everyone saw what happened not working
for Delilah Belle and Amelia gray I
don't know actually I think then because
I Laval and Amelia are literally copying
like word-for-word what the branch I see
to like now we're just having like fill
ila and Familia and Familia and also
they're just fifi and Pella but we both
soon to say about them Adeline is just a
little different so maybe she does have
a chance know also like first of all
Adeline said beautiful also Delilah
doesn't really work as a model anymore
she doesn't know I think she moved back
who's had a choice yes and amelia is
very much like a working model but they
both like I don't think they're so
passionate about modeling anymore like
the show didn't blow them up like
they're I mean you would consider them
celebrities like they are they're
influencing because of the show that the
they're more well-known than the average
influencer yeah because of the show but
it didn't do the fifi fella it did not
do the fifi fella not at all
Betty I'm I'm excited for Adeline and
it's been a while since we've like
champions champions
she enjoyed burgeoning model she used to
go see Fashion Week it's like when we
were watching Gigi on Beverly Hills like
she was doing shoots for like Express
yeah and Yolanda was telling her to stop
eating it like [ __ ] if she's so paid to
have an almond eye so I feel like this
it's a little premature but like I could
see her doing some really the commercial
stuff you know like one where she liked
as a leaf and the smile she looks like
Christine froze off' yeah she's very
pretty
I think she could do it and I thought
she walked great I thought she did when
she was walking in the living room
clodhoppers not too good she couldn't
walk in those shoes yes so Shannon was
giving horrible advice I'm glad that she
listened to Shannon's energy which is
off agreed like it's serious yeah
and she did a good job yeah and she was
just like screaming I'm gonna take that
time to Charlotte pop your hip look shut
up oh my god it's like four add lines if
I would have listened to you what do you
know no she's a thousand percent right
like just watch youtube videos no friend
but like Gigi Mela like they would
listen to Yolanda right cuz she knows
um Keeping Up with the Kardashians we
had Kourtney oh no what happened to
subsumes um what we had the met out
episode we got the birth the robbery oh
yeah we're news being so I'm not Sean
about the robbery like that was a robber
in Rousey was standing there and Chloe
was like go like it was so stupid oh and
then the trip to Turks and Caicos the
girls trip Larsa Barrera and by the way
there's something that happened last
season or the season before where Sarah
Howard was the whoa and we talked about
her on this show we yes and I forget
what it was but she was being like so
[ __ ] annoying I can't remember what
she did well regardless of the actual
fight I just the vibe that I got from
Sarah is that like she's not someone I
would want to hang out with like first
of all the way she talks about like
comparing men to the food that she eats
and how particular she is about safety
like Oh while she's holding a jewel like
it's so chakras apocrypha is so real
also the way that her and Courtney were
talking about like their jobs for [ __ ]
because they have to post they can't
drink that much like if your job is
putting it to Instagram post a day like
you don't even know what hard work is
like she just gave me the vibe of like
someone who's never known real problems
and like just listening to her talk
about like her life in this complex way
when it's like not that complex
ya know she's just really not my kind of
girl like I could barely watch her on TV
let alone hang out with her and I know I
guess it's controversial that I'm like
firmly T Martha it's just that like
Larsa seems like interesting
hang out with and I just like her energy
of like shut up like you have just
saying things that people are thinking
like when she was talking to Sarah and
she was like so I guess that's her
saying that she's single cuz that's how
she was talking all the time it's just
like funny you know Sarah's like Larsa
honestly I understand after this episode
I feel like now so many people are like
I don't understand why the Kardashians
are friends with Larsa after this
episode I actually do understand my
other friends the flare so like she's
funny as [ __ ] I am definitely more of a
Larsa but the one thing that I didn't
agree with Larsa on it's like okay Sarah
was 1,000% being in a weighing like and
honestly probably ruin the trip for a
lot of the girls but like to be so rude
to her face like when we're all grown
adults like it's just someone necessary
like be normal talk about her behind her
back you look like with Malika but as we
saw me I'll have size of Orange County
like don't go and talk about me behind
my back to everyone else say it to my
face
they're not the only friends there
they're only they wouldn't that that's
what they were saying they would never
be on a trip together if it weren't for
the Kardashian so like they don't owe
each other their respective like hashing
out an argument like you can just not
like someone and be a person like Sarah
and a person like Larsa couldn't be more
different and there's no need for them
to be not people to be actual friends so
like they don't need to like have it out
Larsa was definitely being too mean to
her face like nobody in the bathroom and
Larsa just like walked away and like
snickered with like Malika and Khloe it
would've been like oh my god she's so
petty gossip girl and like mean I
supposed to you saying so no do we know
her
why is she crying that girl said I
should we care no because then it makes
it seem like that girl's terroristic so
understand and Larsa so main when it's
like okay that's probably true but that
girl Sarah is like a [ __ ] like like
crying in the bathroom like who [ __ ]
cares like so stupid and I totally hear
Larsa but like when you're on a trip
like that and like you're on TV and now
people are gonna be commenting on how
you act like don't be so mean to
someone's face I'm like so dismissive I
thought it was hilarious and that's what
I like is like she didn't care what she
looked like why are you telling us this
we're having a great time do we know
this girl do you even know why she's
crying and then she was like she
probably left with her boyfriend 20
minutes ago we're still here fighting
about it what about Jackie she was so
right I'm just her delivery but I liked
her like I respect her delivery yeah
also with the guy think she was being
like a little lowing whoo yeah I agree I
think that friend yeah it has his dope
we should go like what it's obvious that
like she told these guys from Miami to
come
so they can hang over the Kardashians
and the Kardashians I didn't want to go
up was like she literally made these
guys fly outlets she had to at least see
them yeah that part of the episode where
also Kourtney needs to speak up and say
like that she doesn't want to do these
things with Lars anymore like that I
understood but in general I feel like
I'm not a Larsa but I like respect the
hell out of her the Larsa hustle yeah
like just the bull Vaughn nature yeah
I'm just like save me what's on your
mind
I also made me really want to go to
Turks and Caicos like that ocean water
oh my god turquoise beautiful also it
was interesting the way they split up
the cars like made me think that like
Khloe like was totally team Lars because
it was just like Malika Larsa Khloe
Kourtney and Khadijah maybe and it's
like that's the crew that's the crew
that I would want to be in course yeah
like I could never hang out with Sarah I
know and like the fact that she's the
co-founder and like the co partner of
pushes of all you need to know has you
everything you need to know yeah sad
yeah that was just hilarious episode um
it was good and we have Dallas tonight
but I did catch up on the last week's
Dallas but we'll recap it all tomorrow
yeah I need to catch up on this week's
and last week's number one episode mind
of dynasty yeah we really talked about
it but the first episode came back and
it just like put set us back like
literally two seasons and I was like
honestly annoyed you guys yeah really
like I love dynasty we'll watch it like
on its last episode but I'm really
hating crystal 3.0 oh my god I'm so
annoyed yeah okay I really liked crystal
1.0 and then when like she had to leave
and they brought in new Kris so I was
annoyed but I came to love crystal 2.0
and now I hate crystal 3.2 and I don't
know what to do I don't blame I don't
know what's the point is it like a joke
or they know they can't find some new I
guess out of Brenda didn't want to do
the show anymore that she apparently
just didn't show up to work still number
one crystal number two Krista number one
they just didn't like her when she
christened everyone was the most cutest
like but no actually I love crystal
number two like us at least like she was
a new character so she had like just
better characteristics where she was
just like funny and and headstrong
where's like now crystal 3.0 has that
same attitude but she can't carry it off
because she goes first Dominique I'm
like sit down please but if it was Anna
Brendan like this girl sucks
like she's moaning of them changing
that's well I guess it's like dynasty
was a soap opera so bringing it like
just changing characters like that like
that's actually something that they
would do and so that's why I mean that
way it's not a big deal but it's so
unacceptable and you know if you need to
get a crystal 3.0 fine but get me the
best crystal of all time I want Penelope
Cruz okay yeah Schumi great yeah I just
it's really bothering me I can't watch
the episode with being like who's this
woman on my television screen I don't
like her no I think she's supposed to be
carrying off the energy of crystal 2.0
but she has the energy of crystal
negative too
you know crystal 2.0 actually was fiery
as [ __ ] yeah and the hair and she's a
great relationship with Liz and now like
sorry Fallon and now Fallon it like what
is she gonna come in and her hair still
like she's still gonna want to touch her
hair that was hilarious I saw the same
hair it's not the same hair yeah it's
it's no bueno but we continue to watch
him we can't you need a stand and we
continue to be a dynasty we continue to
be a dynasty
Oh CNN update Lauren Elizabeth's first
episode just launched today so check it
out support our new TNN show with Lauren
Elizabeth it's called mood with Lauren
Elizabeth and it's available right now
so when you log off of here go head over
at the podcast or and listen to it and
then it'll really be time for lunch so
your days basement and you'll have a
late lunch so then you get back into the
office around like 2 o'clock 3 days over
whoo we love you guys thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so feel free to
subscribe to us on YouTube like this
video give it a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast pretty
much anywhere podcasts can be found so
it Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio
I Heart Radio cast box all the places
subscribe over there leave a five-star
review about how beautiful setting and
smart we are we love you guys so much
have an amazing Wednesday hunk someone
you love me we'll be back tomorrow bye
you